well the speaker House of
Representatives madam percent to the
permission granted in Clause 2h of rule
2 of the rules of the US House of
Representatives I have the honor to
transmit a sealed envelope received from
the White House on March 13 2020 at 5:28
p.m. and said to contain a message from
the President on declaring a national
emergency
concerning the novel coronavirus disease
outbreak with best wishes I am signed
sincerely Cheryl L Johnson at Clerk of
the House report the message to the
Congress of the United States pursuant
to section 201 of the national
emergencies act 50 United States Code
1621 I hereby report that I have
exercised my authority to declare that
the outbreak of coronavirus disease in
the United States constitutes a national
emergency
this declaration invokes section 1135 of
the Social Security Act 42 United States
Code to allow the Secretary of Health
and Human Services to exercise the
authority under that section to
temporarily waive or modify certain
requirements of the Medicare Medicaid
and state children's health insurance
programs of the Health Insurance
Portability and Accountability Act
Privacy Rule throughout the duration of
the public health emergency declared in
response to the CEO of Eid - 19 outbreak
I'm enclosing a copy of the proclamation
I have issued signed Donald J Trump the
White House March 13th
2020 referred to the committee's on
Energy and Commerce and ways and means
and ordered printed
for purposes the gentlewoman from New
York seek recognition
Mr Speaker I move to suspend the rules
and pass the bill HR 6 201 making
emergency supplemental appropriations
for the fiscal year ending September
30th 2020 and for other purposes as
amended the clerk will report the title
of the bill HR 6201 a bill making
emergency supplemental appropriations
for the fiscal year ending September
thirtieth 2020 and for other purposes
pursuant to the rule the gentlewoman
from New York mrs. Lowey and the
gentlewoman from Texas MS Granger each
will control 20 minutes the chair
recognizes the gentlewoman from New York
mrs. Lowey Mr Speaker I ask unanimous
consent that all members have five
legislative days in which to revise and
extend their remarks and include
extraneous material on HR 6 201
currently under consideration without
objection
Mr Speaker I yield myself such time as I
may consume
the gentlewoman is recognized the
families first coronavirus response act
builds on the eight point three billion
dollar supplemental enacted last week to
meet the needs and the American people
by guaranteeing free coronavirus testing
providing paid leave strengthening food
security initiatives through additional
investments in WIC food banks and senior
nutrition the bill also makes sure that
children who depend on free and
reduced-price meals have access to food
during school and childcare closes Mr
Speaker we must help ensure the physical
safety and financial security of our
nation's working families during this
time of
crisis I urge my colleagues to join me
in support of this legislation and I
reserve the balance of my time
the gentlewoman reserves the gentlewoman
from Texas is recognized Mr Speaker I
rise today in support of HR
6201 the second coronavirus relief bill
fiscal year 2020 appropriations bills
were enacted less than three months ago
which included record levels of spending
on our public health infrastructure
this allowed the administration to
respond immediately to the coronavirus
when the threat became clear last week
the House and Senate voted almost
unanimously on an eight billion dollar
emergency supplemental giving the
administration new resources to respond
to the virus unfortunately the threat we
face has grown more complex and costly
in only a week's time the bill before us
will provide a second installment of
supplemental funds and combate the
negative economic effects of this
disease that has now been called a
pandemic this legislation builds off of
last week's bill where we expanded the
availability of tests for the corona
virus to ensure that everyone who needs
to be tested gets tested in his remarks
today the president reaffirmed his
commitment to distribute millions of
tests and speed up how they are
processed this bill takes the next step
to include more than 1 billion dollars
to cover the cost of taking these tests
including for servicemembers and
veterans
we must ensure tester administrated so
that people know if they are infected
this is the only way we can stop the
spread of this virus emergency food
assistance is providing the bill for
seniors women children and low-income
families this includes additional help
for children whose schools are being
closed as a precautionary measure to
keep them safe tax incentives are
included to encourage American
businesses to allow employees to take in
more
see leave to limit spread of the virus
no one should have to choose between
getting a paycheck or infecting other
people we have heard many concerns about
the needs of small businesses in
addition to the tax incentives in the
bill more than 37 billion dollars is
already available from prior
appropriations for the Small Business
Administration to make loans as we watch
the impact of this virus on our nation's
job creators I will continue working
with the administration and my
colleagues to ensure they get the help
they need
while bringing this bill to the floor
has taken much longer than I'd hoped it
is time for Congress to pass it this
bill will give the president and our
public health officials the tools that
are needed right now
to respond to this quickly changing
threat I urge my colleagues to join me
in voting for this measure we must pass
this bill today to help lessen the
devastating impact of this global
pandemic on the American people
thank you and I reserve the balance of
my time the gentleman reserves General
woman from New York is recognized Mr
Speaker I yield such time as he may
consume to the gentleman from
Massachusetts the chair of the Committee
on ways and means mr. Neal the gentleman
from Massachusetts is recognized Thank
You mr. speaker and I thank the
gentlelady I rise in strong support of
this important legislative package to
protect Americans health and financial
security
as our nation confronts the coronavirus
crisis I want to highlight quickly three
policies that the Ways and Means
Committee contributed to the measure
before us this evening first we're
ensuring that coronavirus testing is
provided free of charge it is imperative
that anyone who needs to be tested for
coronavirus is able to afford that
testing if individuals worry that they
can't afford the cost of the tests
they'll forego it and risk endangering
themselves and their community to
provide Americans with the necessary
confidence they need to seek testing
we've included a provision that ensures
free coronavirus testing in Medicare
Medicaid and CHIP as well as for people
enrolled in private insurance the
uninsured tribal communities receiving
care outside of Indian Health facilities
and our military families second we are
making a historic emergency commitment
to paid leave for the American family
members affected by coronavirus one of
our top priorities was to get Americans
affected by coronavirus emergency paid
leave so that they get paid their bills
after intense negotiation with Treasury
we have agreed that this is an emergency
we will require employer's to provide
the leave and reimburse them for the
full cost via tax credits affected
self-employed workers would be eligible
for refundable tax credits in the long
run we need a comprehensive paid leave
program like the one in the family act
and if we had that now we would have be
in a far better place with the options
available to us as workers confront
these challenges finally we are
implementing measures to stabilize the
unemployment insurance system and make
sure that workers access their earned
benefits these provisions will
immediately help States deal with spikes
and unemployment and prepare them for
any future local or national recessions
these provisions give States necessary
flexibility to provide unemployment
insurance to coronavirus affected
individuals without delays caused by
waiting periods and work search
requirements now I want to acknowledge
in closing that the despite the urgency
with which we have worked this
legislation had the benefit of extensive
bipartisan negotiations and thoughtful
consideration my staff has worked around
the clock as always working with ranking
member Brady staff to get bipartisan
input into these provisions the speaker
and I have spent much time on the phone
with the secretary of the Treasury to
ensure along with mr. minuchin that this
bill is a solution that the
administration and both parties in this
institution can support as a result we
have a very good product here I'm
confident this measure will pass
Congress with full bipartisan support
and reach the President's desk without
issue as we face this challenge
Americans are looking to their
government leaders to come together and
present real solutions today we are
doing that we are taking decisive action
to help limit the spread of coronavirus
to allow Americans critical ass access
to testing and to provide families
financial security in the near in the
long term lastly let me acknowledge the
committee staff at the Ways and Means
Committee for the work that they have
put into this legislative achievement
Legislative Council who truly put in a
Herculean effort to assemble this bill
along with leadership staff they worked
around the clock all hours of the day
and night to create the immediacy of
this legislation that will slow the
spread of this virus support our
American workers families and save lives
in particularly I want to acknowledge
the teams on our health worker and
family support select revenue measures
social security subcommittees for their
excellent contributions the American
people will be better equipped to
weather this crisis thanks to their
important bipartisan work and with that
IRS full support for this legislation
and yield back the balance of my time
the gentleman yields back the
gentlewoman from New York reserves mr.
speaker members are reminded to take
their conversations off the floor the
gentlewoman from Texas is recognized I
yield to the gentleman from Texas mr.
Brady for four minutes the gentleman
from Texas is recognized Thank You mr.
speaker president Trump's declaration of
a national emergency is a call to action
to protect Americans health and
well-being and protect the economy this
bill thanks to the leadership of
Secretary of minuchin and leader
McCarthy and working with both sides of
the aisle meets many of these goals the
president has succeeded in working with
the private sector to achieve free
testing and now our bill builds on that
Americans that need lab tests where the
coronavirus will get them free we're
making good on president Trump's promise
to provide financial assistance for
working Americans who were ill
quarantined or caring for others due to
coronavirus and it does so using our tax
code rather than by creating a new
entitlement the original bill contained
provisions that would create undue
burdens on America's small businesses
I've spoken directly with President
Trump a champion of small biz
who agrees that America's small
businesses need flexibility and cash
flow when providing emergency leave for
workers so that they can operate and
survive during this economic challenge
in order to help small businesses and
their workers language has been added to
this bill in President Trump is
directing the secretaries of the
Treasury and labor to write rules to
ensure that small businesses do have the
flexibility to bribe provide paid leave
for their employees they shouldn't have
to be concerned about cash flow when
they work to attain the workers they
need to operate and keep serving their
customers in our communities this is
vital to America's economic rebound this
bill also protects seniors and those
with severe medical conditions by
ensuring that Social Security
Administration is not running a new
permanent mandate we are also able to
stop misguided demands in this bill the
health provisions are now limited to the
Cova 19 without including unrelated
treatments ensuring that pro-life Hyde
Amendment protections remain intact to
prevent taxpayer funds being used for
abortions and Republicans were able to
block efforts to add new burdens on
hospitals that would have overruled the
CDC's science-based guidelines and
prevented critical flexibility for our
local health care providers these are
temporary targeted measures there are
temporary because we've seen what
happens when the bill that's supposed to
be timely targeted and temporary drags
on for years it prolongs economic
hardship we will rebound and we will
rebound strongly good policies one that
strengthens our local communities result
in speedy recoveries in an America we
know we are blessed even when faced with
great adversity we were blessed by the
abundance not only of resources but of
spirit it is that very spirit that will
get us through coronavirus and any other
challenges we face in the future
while today's bill is not perfect it is
another step in the right direction
toward safety and security and a
revitalized economy
I encourage my colleagues to vote for
this bill and then come back to the
table so we can continue our work to
keep American workers and families
prepared safe and healthy with that I
yield back mr. speaker the gentleman
yields the gentlewoman from Texas I urge
a yes vote on this bill and yield back
the balance of my time
gentlewoman yields back the balance
their time the gentlewoman from New York
is recognized mr. speaker the hour is
late vote yes and I yield back
gentlewoman yields back the question is
will the house suspend the rules and
pass the bill HR
6201 as amended those in favor say aye
those opposed no in the opinion of the
chair 2/3 being in the affirmative the
rules are suspended Mr Speaker I ask for
the yeas and nays and the yeas and nays
are requested those favoring a vote by
the yeas and nays will rise
a sufficient number having arisen the
yeas and nays are ordered
members will record their votes by
electronic device
this is a 15-minute vote
on this vote the yeas are 363 the nays
are 41 recorded as present 2/3 being in
the affirmative the rules are suspended
the bill is passed and without objection
the motion to reconsider is laid on the
table
for what purpose does the gentleman from
Maryland seek recognition
mr. speaker mr. speaker the house is not
in order
gentleman's correct the house is not in
order
members are reminded to take their
conversations off the floor
gentleman may proceed priority ok for
what purpose does gentleman seek
recognition
mr. speaker the house has now spoken hmm
in a clear voice and approved this
bipartisan bill the house is not in
order the members are asked to take
their conversations off the floor the
house continues to not be in order the
members are asked to take their
conversations off the floor
the gentleman from Maryland is
recognized I thank the speaker mr.
speaker then as I said the house has now
spoken in a clear voice and approved
this bipartisan bill there are any
developments that would require members
to return before our scheduled return
date of March 23rd 24 hours notice will
be provided I want to thank all members
for their patience as leaders on both
sides worked hard to negotiate the
coronavirus response legislation now has
now adopted much remains to be done but
we have done and good work last week on
behalf of the American people and a good
work this week on behalf of the American
people and I yield back the balance of
my time
the gentleman yields back
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from Wyoming seek recognition
mr. speaker by direction of the House
Republican Conference I send to the desk
a privileged resolution and ask for its
immediate consideration the clerk will
report the resolution House Resolution
903 resolved that the following named
member be and is hereby ranked as
follows on the following Standing
Committee of the House of
Representatives Committee on the
judiciary mr. Jordan
to rank before mr. Collins of Georgia
without objection the resolution is
agreed to and the motion to reconsider
is laid on the table
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from New York seek recognition
Mr Speaker I ask unanimous consent that
in the engrossment of the bill HR 6 201
the clerk be authorized to make
technical Corrections and conforming
changes to the bill what purpose does
the gentleman from Mississippi seek
recognition
Mr Speaker I ask unanimous consent that
the Committee on Homeland Security and
the Committee on Energy and Commerce be
discharged from further consideration of
HR 6160 and I ask for its immediate
consideration in the house the clerk
will report the title of the bill HR
6160 a bill to extend the chemical
facility anti-terrorism standards
program of the Department of Homeland
Security is there objection to the
consideration of the bill without
objection the bill is engrossed read a
third time and passed and the motion to
reconsider is laid on the table
the chair lays before the house the
following enrolled men's senate 1678 an
act to express united states support for
taiwan's diplomatic alliances around the
world
okay the chair will now entertain
requests for one-minute speeches for
what purpose does the gentleman from New
Jersey seek recognition
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute
Mr Speaker I rise today to honor Ruby
white Whittle Smith on the occasion of
her hundredth birthday Miss Smith has
been a district resident for 95 years
she was born in South Hill Virginia on
March 15th of 1920 and moved to Orange
New Jersey
five years later Miss Smith graduated
from Orange High School and later the
New York Institute of Dietetics she
started her career as a hospital
dietician and worked at community
hospital in Newark New Jersey then she
spent 30 years as a clerk at Western
Electric but she is known and loved for
her passions her dedication to New Hope
Baptist Church in East Arne's her
enjoyment of Denzel Washington movies
and her love of peppermints and bingo so
happy birthday to Ruby Ann Whittle Smith
she is truly a hundred years young and
with that I yield back
gentleman yields back for what purpose
does the gentleman from Texas seek
recognition without objection the
gentleman is Thank You mr. speaker
it is quite sad something this important
had this kind of procedure now I got a
bill at around nine o'clock or so I was
told it was the most recent draft I read
through that and I got through it in
time to have a number of questions
highlighted tagged and then we I what
enabled my staff was trying to get a
copy of the bill we were going to vote
on and get it right before the bell
buzzer goes off we're gonna have a vote
in 15 minutes this is no way to handle
something so important part of which my
problem my concerns and questions I
couldn't get answered are gonna put some
people out of business and I get over
here and people hadn't read it so they
can't answer
my questions this is no way to handle
billions and billions of dollars when
we're trying to help people and we don't
even know whether we'll help them or
hurt them I yield back
Jeremy yields back for what purpose does
the gentlewoman from Illinois seek
recognition
without objection the gentlewoman is
recognized for one minute
Thank You mr. speaker the hours late but
I wanted to rise to speak to my
constituents we are facing a novel
illness in the coronavirus and I know
that many are feeling nervous and
uncertain with this type of disease but
I want to remind my community in
northern Illinois that we have some
tools at our disposal common sense
solutions like making sure to wash our
hands and use hand sanitizer to sanitize
frequently touch surfaces and to refrain
from touching our faces but we also need
to make sure that we are extending
common courtesies and kindness and
respect to our neighbors and if you're
feeling sick stay home and if you're
really feeling sick please call ahead to
your health care provider so they can be
ready to accommodate you together our
country will survive the corona virus
and make it through this challenging
time with that I yield back
gentlewoman yields back for what purpose
does the gentlewoman from Texas seek
recognition
without objection the gentlewoman is
recognized for one minute
the speaker's I stand before their words
and god we trust'
tonight we took a vote to save the lives
of our fellow Americans I'm very glad
that what we did today was for families
health care worker protections emergency
paid leave emergency unemployed
insurance paid six days for public
health emergencies and personal and
family care I will go home to my
district and convene meetings regarding
those who are dealing with education
health care and testing but the main
thing that we must do is we must test
every single American that is showing
signs or needs and what we have in this
bill is to provide free testing but in
addition we have organized the
partisan Congressional coronavirus task
force we're doing that to engage with
members as they away in their districts
this is the most contagious more
contagious than the flu and more deadly
let us be assured that we take care of
the American people I intend to do so in
my state of Texas and intend to make
sure that resources go to save lives in
god we trust'
I yield back the gentlewoman yields back
the chair lays before the house the
following personal request leave of
absence requested for mr. Lewis of
Georgia for Friday March 13th without
objection the request is granted
pursuant to section 7 B of House
Resolution 891 the house stands
adjourned until 11:00 a.m. on Monday
March 16 2020